Evo Morales is on his way to Mexico
after it granted him political asylum he
resigned on Monday apparently under
pressure from the military in what he
described as a coup sisters and brothers
I'm leaving for Mexico grateful for the
openness of these brothers who offered
us asylum to protect our life it hurts
to leave the country for political
reasons but I will stay in touch I will
soon return with more strength and
energy since Morales's resignation
Bolivia has been rocked by more unrest
there were scenes of looting in the
capital with buses set on fire mass
protests began over the disputed recent
presidential election with opponents
Morales claiming fraud the final result
gave him just enough of a lead to avoid
a runoff
you